okay we played clips from the whatever
podcast before on this show and uh I
just want to play this one cuz this
one's kind of nice because it's a a very
very viral clip from that show seen a
lot of those but it's not just some
ditsy girl making a fool of herself um
it's partly that but there's also some
real wisdom here as well and let's watch
that a lot of things will be hard for
you to comprehend that's why you're in
sex work because you can't offer value
in the
marketplace what the don't worry
I'm not really talking to you I'm
speaking against you as a symbol a
symbol of what a symbol of a declining
Society where people lack values M so
the point is this if you had IQ and
skills to offer to the marketplace you
can earn a good income being that the
most valuable thing about you is
something that you never earned you
didn't earn knowledge you didn't earn
skills it's your breast that you paid
for and your butthole so you Market that
to earn money which is to say if I took
your brain and placed your brain into a
man's body you would be poverty I'm just
good for nothing yep you comment no you
are good for something that's why you
have only fans and that's my point is
that that's what you're
good there's actually a few clips from
this uh not sure what that guy's name is
but there's all there's a few clips of
his uh interaction with
these girls there
um his name is the saint and the
cner is that is that his legal name well
that's what he goes by so
uh a few clips of his interaction with
these with these girls that I think are
really good and you know thing is look I
mean
it in one sense it's like and this is
why a lot of the clips from the show are
popular because it's kind of it's like
easy pickings it's loow hanging fruit
it's like yeah you could sit there and
you're talking to some bimbo you know
and and it's not hard to embarrass her
um but they could be some real value to
it because I the most interesting thing
about that clip is what he was saying
and then you look at the the girl
sitting right next to the girl that he
was talking to a look of utter and total
shock on her face she's shocked to hear
this you know um and all he's basically
saying is that this is this is degrading
you're selling your body you're turning
your body into an object for sale this
is a grading thing you know uh this is
not this is not how you become a sort of
high value person this just just basic
ideas like in other words it's you
shouldn't do this okay it's it's
degrading and bad for you to be a
prostitute it's it's a disgusting
degrading self-degrading thing that's
that's what he's basically saying saying
a more eloquent way for most homeowners
window replacement isn't something that
they've done before and for many it
isn't something that they want to do but
rather something they have to do if
you've put off replacing windows in your
home because it's too expensive I have
great news you can now get a free inhome
window consultation and a free price
quote from Renewal by Anderson Renewal
by Anderson signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible through the
perfect combination of the best people
in the industry a superior process and
an exclusive product right now Renewal
by Anderson is offering a free inhome or
virtual consultation on durable quality
uh Affordable Windows patio doors for $0
down zero payments and zero interest for
a year text Walsh to 200 300 for their
free consultation to save $375 off every
window and $750 on every door these
savings won't last long so be sure to
check it out by texting Walsh to 200 300
that's Walsh to 200 300 texting privacy
policy in terms of conditions posted at
text plan. us texting en roles for
recurring automated text Market messages
message and data rates apply reply stop
top out go to window appointment now.com
for full offer
details but you look at their reaction
it's like they've never even heard
anyone say that which is which is
amazing and so it's amazing to consider
that because yeah look as they say you
know prostitution is the world's oldest
profession and I don't know if it's the
world world's oldest but it is an old
one it's been around for a long time
thousands of years um
but also for most of those years until
recently yeah you had prostitut what
they call quote unquote sex workers now
but it was understood that this is
a that you know this is a a kind of
dirty
gross degrading thing it's not it's it's
um it's not a praiseworthy
occupation it was always understood that
way everyone knew
that the prostitutes themselves probably
most of
all and now just like these this B basic
reality is shocking to people so you can
have you can have these girls that get
into quote unquote sex
work
and apparently it's like they've never
even heard anyone tell them that hey you
know this is you actually shouldn't do
this okay you're you're worth more than
that just selling off your body parts is
a bad thing you're worth more than that
you shouldn't do this this is not a
respectable
profession they've never heard anyone
say
that um it's it's one of the many basic
truths of
life that these days people can live
their whole lives and never even here
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there